So the most important thing to know
about anxiety straight out of the gate,
is that it has gotten
an unnecessarily bad rap,
as has happened for a lot
of negative emotions.
But you should know that psychologists
have long understood
that anxiety has both healthy forms
and unhealthy forms.
And a lot of the anxiety we experience
in the day-to-day is healthy.
OK, so what makes anxiety healthy?
Anxiety is healthy when it is serving
as an alarm system
that lets us know
that something's not right,
that it gets our attention and helps us
to keep ourselves safe.
So if you're driving and somebody
swerves and cuts you off
and you have a surge of anxiety,
that's a good thing.
It will focus your attention,
it will help you be safe
around that driver,
maybe take evasive maneuvers.
But it's good for you to respond.
If you're entirely indifferent
or relaxed in that setting,
it's not as safe.
So we look for anxiety to be
of help to us, to guide us
and to let us know what we're supposed
to be doing and not doing.
I care for a lot of teenagers clinically,
and, you know, I will say to them,
if you walk into a party that you thought
was going to be a little get-together,
and it turns out it's kind of, you know,
wild and you feel anxious,
pay attention to that reaction.
Like, that's telling you something,
that's indicating that you
may not be as safe
as you thought you were going to be.
So that's healthy anxiety.
The only time we consider
anxiety to cross the line
from healthy to unhealthy
is under two conditions, actually.
One is when we have anxiety,
but there’s no threat,
that there's nothing wrong.
So if it's, you know, a lovely Sunday
morning and you're taking a drive
and there's no traffic nearby,
you shouldn't be having an anxiety
response in that moment.
And if you do, we would consider
that grounds for concern.
The other time we pay
attention to anxiety
and consider it to be unhealthy
is if the anxiety response is way too big
for what's happened,
out of proportion to events.
So if somebody swerves and cut you off
and you have a panic attack
in that moment,
that is not healthy anxiety,
it is not helping you.
And we would address that clinically.
Other than that, we really see anxiety
as largely normal, protective,
healthy and useful in our lives.
OK, all the same,
it feels terrible, right?
I mean, I think one of the things
that's so true about anxiety
is it doesn't feel good
even if it's actually
serving a useful purpose.
And so whether the anxiety
is healthy or unhealthy,
it's really great to know
how to get it in check if you want to.
And that's what I'm going
to teach you now.
And you may be surprised to hear me say,
"Oh, let me just teach you
how to do this,"
because our experience of anxiety
is that it's kind of out of control,
that it sort of takes over.
But despite that,
the reality is that anxiety is probably
the most systematic human emotion.
It unfolds in a very stepwise fashion,
it's actually a one-two-three process
when it really goes off the rails.
And so I'm going to walk you
through the one-two-three
of how anxiety unfolds for all of us.
And then we're going to come back
and I'm going to show you
how at every step of the way
there are things you can do
to bring that anxiety back under control.
OK, so the first thing that happens
when we have an anxiety response
is our bodies react.
There's actually just a physical
reaction that we have,
and it's pretty universal
and it's very familiar to all of us.
Your heart rate accelerates,
your breathing gets
really quick and shallow.
It feels uncomfortable,
there's other stuff happening
in our bodies, too, at the same time.
But that activated heart,
that kind of hyperventilating
sense of breathing,
everybody knows that feeling.
OK, what's happening here?
The sympathetic nervous system,
which is the part of our nervous system
that is paying attention
to the environment,
is sympathetic to what's around us,
is kicking off some degree
of the fight or flight response, right?
That ancient response
that we all know about.
And in the fight or flight response,
what we want to do
is get ready to run or attack.
And so our sympathetic nervous system
is taking measures
to send a whole lot
of heavily oxygenated blood
out to our large muscle groups
for that purpose.
That's why the heart accelerates,
that's why breathing changes.
And I, you know,
especially in caring for people
who have not ever
heard any of this before,
it can be really helpful to understand
that as strange as this reaction is,
it has a sort of ancient logic to it,
may not fit the moment,
but it definitely makes sense.
And it's not something going, you know,
kind of, out of whack when our heart
and our lungs accelerate.
So that's the first thing that happens.
The second thing that happens
is we notice that change in our body
and we come to the conclusion
that we're going to call it anxiety.
We decide to use that label.
This is often an arbitrary decision.
We can call it something else,
but we can sometimes default,
unhelpfully, to calling it anxiety.
And then the third thing that happens,
and this is where things really
do go off the rails,
is we engage in catastrophic thinking.
And the definition of catastrophic
thinking is actually very straightforward.
It's when we overestimate the risks
and we underestimate our ability
to manage the risks.
That's it.
So if your body reacts,
you're like, "I must be anxious,
oh, my gosh, this situation
is completely out of control
and there's nothing I can do to stop it."
That's when anxiety
really becomes miserable.
And that's the one-two-three.
Alright, so knowing that,
let's go back and hit every one of these
in terms of how we can work against them.
So the first one, the body reacting.
OK, so one of the most powerful ways
to get the body to calm down,
is through controlled breathing.
And I will tell you,
if you're having like, this,
"Uh, really, breathing?
Like, you're going to go to breathing?"
I totally get it.
For years, I was like,
"Oh, that's so woo woo.
That's not that technical.
It's not that scientific."
Ok, I was wrong.
I learned I was wrong.
And in fact, breathing is this really
biological intervention.
And what it does is it kickstarts
the parasympathetic part
of our nervous system.
And the parasympathetic nervous system,
its job is to reset the body
to its resting state.
OK, here's how this works,
it's kind of amazing.
So just as the brain can signal
to the heart and lungs
like, "go into overdrive,"
you know, "we might have
to do something here,"
we're also of a mind that the lungs
can communicate back to the brain.
So when we’re anxious,
we’re breathing quickly and ... shallowly.
And if we override that,
if we deliberately deepen
and slow our breathing,
what we think we're doing,
this is sort of the understood science,
is that we are hacking
into a set of nerves
on the surface of our lungs
that are stretch receptors.
And all day, every day,
those nerves are paying attention
to our breathing
to keep us safe.
And they notice that we
have slowed our breathing
and things have gotten calmer
and they read that as evidence of safety
because we only breathe deeply
and slowly when we're safe.
And they send that message
up to the brain saying,
"you're kind of having a reaction
that doesn't make sense
because the nerves on the lungs
are telling us that we must be safe."
And that's how anxiety
comes under control.
That's step one.
Step two, if we want to, need to,
is to consider whether anxiety
is the right name for what's happening.
That we have a kind of activated
response all the time.
So it might be like, I was excited
for this presentation.
And before this presentation,
I kind of felt a little bit of a rev.
I could have said, "I must be anxious."
But instead I said,
"No, I think I'm really excited."
And that shift in thinking
actually makes a huge difference
in terms of how we feel
about what we're engaging.
The third thing we want to watch out for
is anxiety going off the rails
with catastrophic thinking.
And again, that's overestimating risk,
underestimating our ability to handle it.
So if something is feeling really,
really scary to you,
really, really anxiety-provoking,
key questions to ask yourself are,
"Am I imagining this to be worse
than it might really be?"
So you're going to try to bring
that estimation of risk down.
And also, "Do I have more say
in how this is going to go
than I'm giving myself credit for?"
"Are there things I can do to actually
increase my sense of control,
not feel as helpless as I do right now?"
So you're not trying to get rid
of the anxiety entirely,
but you're trying to sort of
get it in the narrower band
of not overestimating risk
and not underestimating your own powers.
So I'm going to start to wrap up,
but here is the bottom line.
Most of the time,
we don't need to feel anxious
about feeling anxious.
It really is there to help us out.
And whether we want it there or not,
or whether it's helping us or not,
if we want to get it under control,
knowing the basics of how it unfolds
really does put you in the driver's seat
of knowing how to calm yourself
when you feel anxious.
And so you don't have to feel
like it's something
that you are at the mercy of.
David Biello: You spoke about breathing
and how you were skeptical
in the early days.
Do you have the particular
breathing practice you like?
Lisa Damour: I do.
Once I got over my snobbery
about breathing,
I use something called
square breathing or box breathing.
And, you know, people
have often heard of this.
And it's really simple.
It’s where you breathe in
on a count of three,
so one, two, three, in --
and I'm actually going to walk us
through it as a group.
Then you hold it for a count
of three: one, two, three.
Then you exhale slowly
on a count of three: one, two, three.
And then you wait, one, two, three.
So, one, two, three, in.
One, two, three, hold.
One, two, three, exhale.
One, two, three, wait.
OK, so let's all do it together.
But here is my instruction to you.
If you really want this to work,
picture the nerves on the surface
of your lungs getting the message.
You're not just breathing
to breathe, right?
You're breathing because you are
hacking into this system
and using those nerves to communicate
to your brain that everything's OK, right?
So everybody, like, (Exhales)
blow out breath a little bit, ready?
Breathe in slowly.
One, two, three.
Hold it.
Exhale slowly, one, two, three.
Now, pause.
One, two, three.
That’s it. (Laughs)
And you can do it a few times.
If you get really anxious a lot,
you should be practicing this
when you're not anxious
so that you can slip
right into that groove.
But it is powerful.
It is really powerful.
And I am a little embarrassed
about how long it took me
to get on the breathing train.
DB: I mean, it's actually incredible
because just doing that with you,
you know, the little ball of whatever,
excitement in my stomach
just sort of dissipates.
So breathing, people, it's real.
It's important.
So we already have some
questions flooding in.
And I want to make this useful
for the members.
Let's get right to them.
First up, Gordon wants to know
about helping other people.
How can we help if we notice
that a friend or a family member
is experiencing excessive anxiety?
LD: OK, I love this question.
So the first thing I would say
just by being generally useful,
is, we'll get to the excessive piece,
but just, people need validation
that anxiety makes sense
most of the time.
And one of the real hazards
of anxiety being talked about
as though it's everywhere
and always pathological
is that people experience normal anxiety
and then they think,
"Oh, I'm having anxiety.
Oh, no, there's something really wrong."
And so one quick thing you can do to say
[to] somebody who’s anxious
if they’re like, “Oh my gosh, I have
a big talk tomorrow and I’m anxious,”
you can say, “You’re having
the right reaction ...
That's going to give you energy and juice.
There's nothing wrong
with being anxious about a talk"
or "there's nothing wrong
with having to go tell your boss
something they don't want to hear.
And that making you anxious,
that's evidence that you work perfectly."
So that alone reassures people a lot.
And then I think the next step
you can do is to say,
"If it gets uneasy,
if it gets to be too much more anxiety
than is helpful to you, right?” --
Even framing it is like, “This should
help you out until it doesn’t.” --
“You can actually dial it back.”
So walk them through why breathing works.
Everybody knows
they're supposed to breathe.
Very few people know why.
And so that's why people won't do it.
And so when I'm caring
for people, I will say,
think about your anxiety
being on a dial, right?
And if it's a zero to 10 dial,
two to three, you actually
tend to do a better job
with whatever you're needing to do
if you have a little energy, a little rev.
Once it gets into four, five, six, seven,
you start to be in trouble.
And so I teach people to use the breathing
to actually turn down the dial.
But that idea of like,
you're not at the mercy of this.
You can be in the driver's seat on this
and you can use breathing or reframing
or questioning your own thinking,
is really helpful because there is
a general sense of like,
we're helpless in the face of anxiety,
and we're really not.
DB: So Catarina describes an anxiety
that leads them to avoid things.
So meeting new people because it’s scary.
Do you --
What do you recommend for that kind
of avoidance tactic around anxiety?
LD: Oh, Catarina, I'm so glad
you brought up avoidance.
This is actually the most important
thing we need to say
when it gets to talking about anxiety.
So, when we're frightened of something,
our instincts are like,
"Get away."
And if that is a tiger or a bad driver,
those are really good instincts.
And so when we remain frightened
of something that's in our everyday lives,
we can actually feel very
compelled to avoid it.
Here is, if you remember anything
from what we talk about today,
these are the three words
I want you to remember most.
Avoidance feeds anxiety.
So here's the process.
It's actually a wonderfully --
I think it's fascinating science on this.
So say, Catarina, you're
thinking about going to a party.
You've been invited to a party
and you're like, OK,
"I'm going to try to go to this party."
And then it's time to go to the party
and you feel your anxiety
starting to bubble up
and you're like, "Forget it.
I'm going to cancel."
OK, here's what's going to happen.
You'll go from feeling very, very anxious
to suddenly feeling much, much better.
So this is the first helping of
how avoidance feeds anxiety,
which is that it feels good.
That, we call it a reinforcing experience.
You felt bad, you avoided,
you feel better.
So you're like, avoidance is kind of fun.
Or not fun, but it solves the problem.
Here comes the second helping.
Because you haven't gone to the party,
nothing challenges your beliefs
about how frightening that party is.
The party remains whatever you
have pictured in your mind --
people not talking to you, you know,
people, you know, whatever.
Like whatever you have imagined
about what makes that party scary
goes unchallenged.
If you actually go to the party,
you often find it's a little bit,
if not a lot, better than you expected.
But if you don't go,
it remains very frightening.
So that is how avoidance actually
entrenches anxiety over time.
It feels good to do it and it actually
doesn't give us any competing data.
So when you go see a clinician
for treatment of anxiety,
often we will start by asking
about what are you avoiding
as a result of your anxiety?
And we will work with you
on -- we call it graduated exposure,
which is like basically baby steps --
getting you in there, right?
So we'll say, OK,
could you go to a small thing
with a couple people?
Could you use your breathing
to make that bearable?
And it would just sort of work you
into it very, very slowly,
because the solution to anxiety
is often what we call exposure,
making yourself do it.
But you are not alone
in this sense of like, you know,
why not just not go?
It feels better to not go.
And that's something that we,
as clinicians, work really hard on.
And I will tell you, you know,
the pandemic and kids and school,
you know that, and, you know,
we've always known if this child
is frightened of school,
the solution is get them to school.
Even if they sit in the teacher’s ...
back office for the day.
Physically being at school
is better than being home
if it's otherwise safe
for them to be there.
DB: So another ...
Area of anxiety
that's popping up in the chat
is dealing with it
in our sort of, children.
Robert wants to know what,
or are there any differences
between words like
anxiety and worry or fear
as it might pertain to how
a teenager is describing
or trying to put a name
to what they're feeling?
LD: I think it means for the kid
whatever it means.
But I will say teenagers use
the term anxiety a lot,
and they use it very broadly.
And I've been practicing
for a very long time.
And then in the last I'd say 10 years,
I started to notice,
like, kids use this term a lot
and I wasn't quite sure
what to make of it.
And then I was actually
rereading "Jane Eyre" --
no, it was "Pride and Prejudice."
And Mrs. Bennet, I don't know
if you remember her,
she's like, the kind of piece
of work mom in that book.
There is a line in the book that was,
"Whenever Mrs. Bennet was discontented,
she fancied herself to be nervous."
And I thought, Oh, I think that's often
what I'm seeing with teenagers,
is they'll say, "I feel anxious"
when they usually mean not calm.
"I don't feel calm."
And so the first thing
I would do if a teenager says
"I feel anxious" is to say,
"Tell me what's going on."
And they might say, you know,
“I’ve got a big try out tomorrow”
or, you know, “This concert is happening
that I’m going to with my friends.”
And listen for the possibility
that it’s something besides anxiety.
It could be they're excited,
they're amped, they're apprehensive.
So try to make more granular
their description of what is causing
the stirred-up feeling.
And sometimes they are anxious.
And that's when there's a threat, right?
Like, "I'm feeling anxious because I have
my driver's test tomorrow
and I am not ready."
That is anxiety.
There is a threat, they could fail
that driver's test, right?
So listen for a threat and then ...
if they’re anxious about something,
be like, “Yeah, of course you’re anxious.
That's kind of scary.
Let's see what we can do
to reduce your sense of risk,
increase your sense of control."
But often it's very important
that we help them
bring more nuance
to the language they use
around a sort of sense
of being stirred up.
And what's so nice is that act
of a teenager saying or a kid saying,
“I feel really anxious
about school tomorrow.” --
“What’s making you anxious?” --
"New classroom, new kids, don't know
where things are going to be."
You say, "Yeah, you should
feel apprehensive,
there's a lot there,
and also maybe a little excited."
If you can get in there
with words that are more accurate
than the big generic of anxiety,
that act is in and of itself therapeutic.
Kids are like, "Yes,
I am apprehensive and also excited."
That they feel heard, they feel better,
and they have a better language.
So what I watch for especially,
is kids saying, "I have anxiety."
I like to say, “You’re feeling anxious.”
Because I think, there is
this sense of, “I have anxiety,”
I think there's very much among
adolescents a sense of like,
"I have anxiety,"
but I try not to say, well, everybody
has anxiety at some level
because I don't want to be dismissive,
but to really help them
make that distinction
between a feeling that comes and goes,
and a diagnosis they would need
to be concerned about.
DB: Several folks want to know
how can they tell when to seek help,
when anxiety has become too crippling?
LD: This is a great place to wrap up.
This is a perfect place to wrap up.
So mostly this has been an ad for anxiety.
Like, don't be frightened of it.
Be curious about it.
Trust that it’s trying
to tell you something.
If it feels too uncomfortable,
try these strategies
to get it under control.
But two conditions.
Let's go back to them.
If you feel like your
anxiety is showing up
and there's no reason,
like, there's no threat,
there's nothing to be worried about,
that would be a great time
to seek out support.
The other is if your anxiety like,
well, there's a threat,
but like my anxiety is off the charts
and making me miserable
or getting in the way of my life,
that's a good time to seek support.
So, you know,
pretty straightforward in terms
of how we define
what we consider concerning.
But I really want you to know,
most anxiety does not need to make you
feel anxious about its own presence.
[Want to support TED?]
[Become a TED Member!]
[Find out more at ted.com/membership]